vous dites dans une de vos homélie
françois espérer que l'époque est à la
moralité et au puritanisme à une
amoralité vertueuse et un puritanisme
vicieux comme un vieux libertin qu'est
ce que vous entendez par là c'est quoi
une amoralité vertueuse et c'est quoi un
puritanisme vicieux je suis assez je
suis alors le puritanisme vicieux on a
tous rencontrés depuis toujours chez
tous les gens qui sont très épris de
morale parce que c'est la seule manière
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont de de masquer aux
yeux du monde ou à leurs yeux propre
leur leur désir sur sur la moralité
vertueuse je suis assez frappé de voir
en ce moment le retour de la morale
comme le retour d'un refoulés dans un
monde où on a chassé dieu et si je
regarde les l'es12 où les 24 les 24
derniers mois en france dans le débat
public
les les torquemada on a croisé ici ou là
étaient principalement des torquemada
qui jurent leurs grands dieux qu'ils ne
croient pas en dieu et que dieu n'existe
pas et pourtant ils sont habités par une
espèce de moral d'autant plus dangereuse
pour leur prochain que ils l'ignorent et
qu il la conteste donc c'est un peu
terrifiant
on est toujours moins dangereux quand on
est un possédé mais qu'on le sait que
quand on est habité par un démon tout en
croyant être parfaitement libre et je
trouve que les possédés d'aujourd'hui
sont pas forcément les intégristes
religieux mais sont les impressions des
gens qui ont l'impression d'avoir
dépassé la question de dieu et
et qui se retrouve à peu près au même
niveau que des ligues de vertu à
l'époque de la prohibition aux états
unis
[Musique]